mais d'abord un président français un
premier ministre hongrois adversaires
politiques et partenaires européens
nicolas fleury
ce sont deux adversaires
nous avons des désaccords politiques qui
sont connus
mais nous avons la volonté de travailler
ensemble pour cette europe et d'être des
partenaires loyaux qui peuvent en même
temps être des alliés message
d'équilibriste défendue aujourd'hui par
emmanuel macron en visite à budapest en
pleine crise entre l'europe et viktor
orban car le premier ministre hongrois
refuse de se soumettre au droit européen
il est critiqué pour son hostilité
envers les migrants ces atteintes à la
liberté de la presse et ses attaques
contre les lgbt
il n'y a pas de place pour les
bureaucrates de bruxelles ici et quoi
qu'ils fassent nous ne laisserons pas
les activistes lgbt côtoyé nos petits
dans les écoles et les jardins d'enfants
tension maximale cet été quand viktor
orban n'interdit de montrer
l'homosexualité aux mineurs à la
télévision par exemple
aussitôt les dirigeants européens
dénoncent un texte homophobes ce projet
de loi hongrois est une honte il va à
l'encontre de toutes les valeurs
fondamentales de l'union européenne
pour moi la hongrie n'a plus rien à
faire dans l'union mais je ne suis pas
le seul à décider
pourtant emmanuel macron espère bien
faire de la hongrie un partenaire
stratégique en matière de défense et
d'énergie nucléaire des thèmes au
programme de la présidence française de
l'union européenne qui démarre le 1er
janvier aujourd'hui l'elysée a promis de
ness qui vers aucun sujet emmanuel
macron doit d'ailleurs rencontrer le
principal opposant à viktor orban une
façon de prendre un peu de distance avec
le dirigeant en droit alors qu'il ya
quelques semaines j'ai eu plaisir à tout
à l'heure de discuter avec viktor orban
il recevait deux candidats à la
présidentielle eric zemmour et marine le
pen
et on débat autour de la personnalité de
viktor orban ait du sens de cette visite
du président français avec mes
invitèrent mais le charrier bon soit
vous êtes éditorialistes en politique
internationale à france 24 sylvain kahn
bonsoir à vous aussi
historien géographe spécialiste de
l'union européenne géopolitique et de sa
construction professeur à sciences po
paris et puis vous publiez histoire de
la construction de l'europe depuis 1945
sept aux puf aux presses universitaires
de france puis reconnaissable en soit
rejeté essayiste ancien fonctionnaire
vous publiez le lobby saoudien en france
comment vendre un pays invendables c'est
aux éditions denoël j'accueille
également fabienne keller qui étaient
avec lui ou en duplex députée européenne
soit j entends soir au sein du groupe
renaissance au parlement européen et
lætitia cru pas une crise politique qui
soit elle sera à mes côtés tous les
jours cette semaine et on fait un coucou
amical évidemment à
matthieu croissandeau peut-être une une
définition une présentation pour vous de
viktor orban qu'est-ce qui vient
spontanément quand vous devez définir le
le premier ministre ont recommencé avec
vaud cilv incarne la figure de proue de
libéralisme en europe libéralisme ça
c'est une définition intéressante c'est
à dire que c'est une démocratie libérale
c'est même le terme qu'il emploie c'est
ça oui alors il n'a pas inventé mais
c'est vrai que c'est lui qui l'a on va
dire un peu théorisé dans l'union
européenne valait libéralisme en fait
c'est l'idée que l'on peut être une
démocratie
sans respecter l'état de droit et sans
respecter le pluralisme voilà c'est ça
armelle charest ce qu'il peut
effectivement variés tout casser sa
définition je pense que victor mendy
joue sur plusieurs points c'est il est
détesté de beaucoup il se positionne
comme ça en europe en même temps il est
assez stratège parce que ça lui a permis
de mettre une césure dans l'europe et de
porter une vision différente d'une
europe qui soient évidemment plus
nationale on reprend sur la question des
immigrés mais ensuite derrière de
valeurs européennes qui prend à sa main
en disant il faut les défendre nous
sommes aussi une europe chrétienne et il
faut la prendre alors finalement dans la
rencontre macron et à victor hörmann on
retrouve deux hommes qui ont la volonté
d'avoir une stature européenne
qui reconnaît ça comment vous le
définiriez vient d'où tient dans
l'échiquier politique hongrois viktor
orban ni l'a toujours été
nationaliste à l'extrême il était
d'abord un opposant locaux mise quand
même c'est un carrière politique
commence à ce moment là puis ensuite
effectivement il va prendre la tête d'un
mouvement politique qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui il est le premier
ministre qui a la plus longue longévité
politique en hongrie donc il est
représentatif de quelque chose quand
même heure la deuxième chose c'est que
la hongrie comme la pologne sont des
pays qui ont une histoire assez
différente parce qu'ils ont eu 35 ans ou
40 ans de communisme et quand en 89 il
commence à apprendre l'indépendance ils
découvrent si vous voulez la possibilité
de décider pour eux-mêmes même s'il
entre dans l'europe donc ils ont un peu
le sentiment d'être passés de la tutelle
de moscou si vous voulez la tutelle de
bruxelles et il faut être sensible à cet
aspect là parce que je voudrais pas
exagérer mais enfin vous savez c'est le
pays qui la langue russe un tout petit
pays ces dix millions d'habitants 1
c'est le pays qui a vu transiter ou qui
a accueilli le plus grand nombre
d'immigrants par rapport à sa population
et c'est à celui là qu'on va donner des
leçons en expliquant qu'elle ait le
droit de votre ange dors chez vous mais
cela veut dire pour les endroits que la
priorité soit pas tout à fait celle de
bruxelles il faut aussi la prendre en
compte fabienne keller on entendait dans
le reportage de
de ces plaintes il l'a fait excuser moi
ça s'appelle un trou de mémoire nicolas
fleury merci beaucoup il avait le pincer
qui est à côté de moi qui est la
rédactrice en chef de l'émission et qui
est dans mon oreillette et là lors il ya
une petite heureusement qu'elle est là
là bref nicolas fleury pardon et merci
on entendait une voix pour dire mais il
faut l'exclure de l'europe qu'est ce que
vous répondez à ça prévient qu'elle est
assez souvent pensé bas on est en
difficulté parce que il représente un
pays qui a accepté les valeurs de
l'union au moment de l'entrée donc dans
les années 90 puis officiellement en
2004 il a été dirigeant clairement dans
ce cadre est désormais il s'en éloigne
c'est à dire qu'ils ne respectent plus
du tout les principes de la séparation
des pouvoirs
il a pris progressivement le contrôle de
la justice on entre par le même plus
tellement ça fait longtemps il n'y a
plus aucune presse libre dans son pays
ils pratiquent la corruption il
nourrissait ses proches et il a fixé un
certain nombre de cibles parmi lesquels
la technocratie bruxelloise les lgbt i q
les juifs aussi on oublie sa campagne il
faut pas oublier sa campagne contre
soros au motif de l'université mais en
fait c'était une autre cible et puis
également les migrants donc qu'il a une
stratégie très ciblées mais il est
habile
parce que de temps en temps il s'est
donné raison à l'une ou l'autre règles
de l'union européenne pour donner le
sentiment qu'il s'y conformeraient tout
au contraire la transformer la loi
hongroise
pour beaucoup de clauses de nominations
notamment il faut les deux tiers de
majorité dans son assemblée ce qui est
pratiquement inaccessible un parti
démocratique ou à l'ensemble de la de
l'opposition qui est coalisés
entièrement contre lui ils se sont
organisés tous ensemble pour essayer de
l'emporter en avril prochain alors ce
qui est intéressant on l'a vu dans le
temps dans le reportage tout à l'heure
c'est que évidemment et eric zemmour et
marine le pen se sont succédé à budapest
en valais on va écouter d'abord eric
zemmour c'est le 24 septembre dernier
pour lui le premier ministre hongrois
n'est pas autoritaire écoutez je ne
pense pas très vite vannes soit un
dirigeant autoritaire il dirige son pays
et il ne se laisse pas
intimider par
ni lui ni les minorités agissantes ni
les médias ni le gouvernement des juges
c'est exactement ce qu'il faudra en
france ça veut pas dire un gouvernement
autoritaire
c'est intéressant c'est une source
d'inspiration
dans le petit tour de table justement
j'étais en train de réfléchir et je me
suis dit tiens je vais lui dire leader
autoritaire parce que c'est
immédiatement le mot qu'on a envie
d'utiliser mais un autre mot aussi assez
populistes voilà le populisme je sais
que c'est vraiment le mot tiroir un peu
qui sert à rentrer tout mais c'est
vraiment l'incarnation du populisme
viktor orban et c'est vrai que eric
zemmour a tout intérêt à dire que
finalement il n'est pas autoritaire
parce qu'il est dans son sillon ils ont
les mêmes obsessions l'immigration et à
gvt les femmes les élites les juges et
puis le protectionnisme donc c'est vrai
que c'est un peu dans le sillon d'un or
bad et bien sûr à la française parce que
on essaye toujours de comparer mais on
sait qu'il ya bien sûr des achats pas d
exception culturelle à chaque pays
mais c'est quand même voilà parfumé
populisme le sillage de durban et 2 et
moi alors je vous voyais je voudrais
aller c'est sur cette question d'
autoritarisme et finalement de liberté
liberté de la presse liberté des
opposants qui reconnaissent à jouer les
tickets tout à l'heure dans la liste que
faisait fabienne keller pourquoi bon
parce qu'on a l'impression si vous
voulez que c'est une shopping list c'est
à dire on est en train de chercher tout
ce qu'on peut reprocher à tout ce qu'on
peut reprocher à sorbonne et dieu sait
qu'il y en a mais en plus on veut
raccrocher aux élections françaises en
dix ans maintenant et si en plus il a
reçu zemmour qu'il a reçues marine le
pen donc là on est sûr si vous voulez
que c'est vraiment un méchant enfin ce
type est réélu est réélu il ya des
élections en avril dans son vin on veut
en arabie saoudite salué un des pires
dictateurs théocratique de la planète et
en exemple demande s'il faut aller un
camp entrer en contact avec un membre de
l'union européenne qui a été réélu donc
il ya un espèce d'inversion de valeur
que je joue un peu scandaleuse quand
même esquissée dès qu'il ya une jadot
qui se demande le fait même pour des ce
débat il le fait il le fait parce qu'il
ya beaucoup de sujets qui sont
intéressants ça va au delà de est-ce que
viktor orban est fréquentable ou une
fréquentable et effectivement si sylvain
kahn cette question on peut écouter
thierry yannick jadot le député le
candidat d'europe écologie les verts à
la
l'élection présidentielle je prends un
peu de temps parce que ça fait sale à la
régie l'occasion de me suivre on va
écouter c'était ce matin effectivement
il dit pour le pour yannick jadot il
faut pas aller à budapest l'écoutant on
peut lui serrer la main parce que c'est
un dirigeant européen mais on va pas
chez lui un partenaire
non c'est bien des dirigeants européens
banio fait emmanuel macron fait la
visite en or ban il rend service au fond
à la mise en scène durban il le fait
juste après zemmour et le pen je pense
qu'il faut rencontrer tout l'ensemble
des dirigeants européens c'est sa
responsable des autres c'est ça voilà
c'est ça résonneront ne l'invitent pas
non plus en france victorieuse lannion
va inviter tous les dirigeants france
mais est-ce qu'on est obligé de mettre
en scène or ban chez lui avec
effectivement les lois anti lgbt qui
passe dans son pays les mesures contre
la liberté de la presse les mesures
contre l'indépendance des universités je
comprends pas bon c'est peut-être pas le
sur ces arguments que yannick jadot et
plus le plus percutant où je sais pas ce
que vous en pensez c'est un peu
jésuitique un sabot jésuitique de dire
oui on peut rencontrer viktor orban mais
pas chez lui un peu le char à bruxelles
peut être à paris en réalité tout dépend
de ce que dit emmanuel macron en
présence de victor sorbonne quand il à
budapest moi j'ai un souvenir assez
assez fort d'une conférence de presse
conjointe je crois bien que c'était à
budapest il y avait enlevé la merkel et
viktor orban et un gala merkel et qui
étaient à côté de victor ban a dit c'est
en 2014 en 2015 je crois en guérit
merkel a dit ce qu'elle pensait de
viktor orban à viktor orban quels
conseils de libéralisme par ailleurs
emmanuel macron je veux pas spécialement
défendre manuel macron méprisant la
république française va également
rencontrer le maire de budapest qui est
dans l'opposition sur le plan national
il rencontre le candidat de l'opposition
aux élections présidentielles bon il se
recueille sur la tombe
la philosophe agnès l air qui était
l'une des opposantes
marquante a eu tort ben oui la guerre
aux intérêts dont l'âge en fait jadot
pense plus ou moins la même chose que
macron mais cherchent un sens des mac à
s'en démarquer parce qu'on est en pleine
campagne pour l'élection présidentielle
non moi il me semble que
bon les endroits sont dans l'ue voilà
effectivement la démocratie libérale car
un concept inventé par fareed zakaria en
constate qu' il y à des pays où ils
continuer à avoir des élections
parlementaires tous les cinq ans mais où
est ce qu'on pourrait appeler
l'écosystème de la démocratie libérale
est de plus en plus animé ou atténuée ça
veut dire qu'il n'y a pas de presse
libre ou très peu de presse libre
partisans y a il ya moins très slims
sait pas qu'il ya une censure c'est que
économiquement c'est très compliqué pour
la presse d'opposition de trouver des
annonceurs petit à petit les
et les financements on va dire de la
presse deviennent tous entre les mains
d'entreprises qui sont elles-mêmes entre
les mains d'affidés durban la seule
presse libre aujourd'hui on la trouve
uniquement sur internet sur les pure
players donc veut pas dire qu'il n'a pas
être du tout un don il faut cercle ce
qui est un peu compliqué avec le
libéralisme c'est que ça ressemble à une
dictature de type entre deux guerres
mais en vérité c'est pas une dictature
de type entre deux hier c'est un peu
différent régime libéral et un régime
autoritaire mais justement dans un
régime libéral il ya quand même des
élections il ya quand même des espaces
de liberté mais aussi est ce cas la
russie est un régime autoritaire pour
vous oui mais justement en russie les
élections sont clairement pas libre il
n'y a pas le droit de manifester par
exemple il ya deux ans ou trois ans
enfin jouer ça devait être trois ans
quand le parlement hongrois a fait
passer une loi qui autorisait les
entreprises à obliger les salariés à
faire des heures supplémentaires 400 par
an et ha et leur permettait de payer les
heures supplémentaires
trois ans après qu'elle ait été effectué
le parlement hongrois a voté ça il ya eu
des manifestations organisées par les
syndicats bon dans un pays où il ya des
manifestations en général on a quand
même l'impression qu'on est plutôt dans
un pays libre que dans un pays
dictatorial voilà donc les régimes
libéraux en particulier en europe c'est
quelque chose d'hybride et nouveau alors
évidemment on a tendance à dire assez
des fascistes banon les fascistes ce
n'était pas exactement la mer entre la
digue la démocratie il ya justement les
régimes autoritaires et donc avec un
sanglier médias libres comme en russie
oui il est toujours ralenti moi je pense
que vous
en russie envers les opposants
politiques en prison on les met dans des
parents bah non non on n'est pas les en
ont mais pas les opposants politiques en
prison voilà ce débat il sert à ça aussi
a par contre lyon m'a dit je suis subtil
on va dire de ce qui est bon alors à
partir de là la hongrie est dans lieux
d'accord elle ils ont lieu alors ma
recruteurs qu'on a vu tout à l'heure le
premier ministre hollandais qui est avec
viktor orban le plus ancien dirigeant
européen actuellement poste il est
arrivé au pouvoir en 2001 il faut qu'ils
sortent l'ifo qui sortent mais bon comme
un diable c'est comme si enfin je vais
je vais faire une analogie qu'on peut
plus qu'on peut encore un peu
schématique mais c'est comme si les gens
qui en france considéré que prenons eric
zemmour par exemple où le rassemblement
national qui ont pu dont les dirigeants
ont pu être à certains moments condamné
par exemple pour incitation à la haine
raciale
c'est comme ça il ya des gens qui
violent la loi et la constitution dont
il faut les exclure alors que pourtant
ils ont obtenu des suffrages ils ont des
députés à l'assemblée nationale bon à
l'échelle européenne c'est pareil est-ce
qu'on va exclure la hongrie parce que la
majorité des hongrois ont élu un
gouvernement qui ne respecte pas l'état
de droit alors qu'il ya 40 à 49 % des
hongrois qui vote pour l'opposition et
que si ça se trouve en mars prochain aux
prochaines élections législatives
hongroises viktor orban ne va passer
dans l'opposition qui est intéressant
aussi
deux hommes la france et l'allemagne
pardon pour la malle les deux hommes ils
sont l'un et l'autre en campagne
électorale donc est ce que finalement
une visite comme celle là pour emmanuel
macron s adresse pas d'abord à
l'électorat français est finalement dans
l'attitude de viktor orban ne s'est pas
aussi à son électorat prioritairement
vous avez raison c'est là où et puis
quand on fait de la rencontre c'est
qu'on est à la fois dans une histoire
européenne est à la fois dans une
histoire de politique intérieure pour
emmanuel macron il ya certainement
beaucoup d'intérêt à aller discuter avec
viktor orban d'abord parce qu'il dit est
obligé il va prendre la présidence de
l'union européenne donc à partir de ce
moment là il faut qu'ils rencontrent
l'ensemble des pays européens je crois
que ça clôt le débat à un moment donné
c'est simplement il est dans un état de
diplomatie il faut qu'ils allaient le
pouvoir il faut qu'il aille rencontrer
et puis parce que lorsqu'il tend la main
à viktor orban certes il y en a qui vont
être choqués mais y'en a qui vont
considérer qu'il a bien faire ça parce
que effectivement on est quand même avec
des personnes qui peuvent avoir des
valeurs dans laquelle ils vont se
retrouver dans viktor orban elles sont
aujourd'hui courtisé par l'as grimm qui
zemmour marine le pen et sa nièce va
tout le monde se précipite mais derrière
emmanuel macron il a aussi une marche de
gens qui peut récupérer en disant on
peut avoir aussi une vision de l'europe
qui soit une vision de l'europe plus
nationaliste avec des vraies questions
sur l'immigration qui sont pas forcément
d'aller dans les excès c'est à dire de
dire on interdit l'immigration on met
des migrants d'or etc mais en tout cas
je suis intéressé par comprendre
pourquoi ce pays se positionne de cette
manière là et là déjà on est dans un
autre pas en quelque sorte viktor orban
lui il a intérêt à montrer effectivement
politique intérieure que il n'est pas
rejetée par tous en plus emmanuel macron
est assez fin quand ils arrivent ils dit
je vais aller en voir aussi tous les
pays devise grade c'est à dire il a donc
ça c'est très dommage
tchèque la slovénie et la pologne est en
fait c'est toute cette fracture en fête
européenne dans laquelle on est en train
d'assister de gens qui sont en train de
se positionner qui n'ont pas envie de
sortir de l'union européenne mais qui a
envie de dire on n'est pas pro occident
on n'est pas d'accord avec la vision
européenne de l'occident et là
effectivement si le président macro on
ne commence pas à y mettre le fait qu'
on peut en discuter ça veut dire qu ils
s'excluent complètement à la fois de cet
électorat et de ce jeu diplomatique
et comme il se veut le président de
l'europe derrière il va falloir de toute
manière qu'il aborde ces sujets parce
que l'europe va les lui a portés pendant
les six mois qui vont venir fabienne
keller je reviens vers vous pour
rebondir peut-être sur ce que disait
sylvain kahn tout à l'heure et est ce
que emmanuel macron doit profiter de
voilà de ceux de ce séjour pour faire
passer aussi des messages
peut-être même ou alors aux français
mais peut-être même endroit
toute assez j'ai trouvé que sa démarche
était d'aller certes rencontré viktor
orban mais aussi le peuple hongrois
quand il va rencontrer le maire de
budapest quand il va rencontrer le
candidat donc d'union de l'opposition il
s'adresse à l'autre moitié du peuple
hongrois quand il va sur la tombe
d'agnès et l'air il salue les mouvements
intellectuels hongrois donc c'est un
grand respect pour le peuple hongrois je
pense qu'il a voulu manifester dans une
démarche a été dit mais je voudrais leur
dire qui est normal en satin pour
quelqu'un qu'il va exercer la présidence
de l'union européenne
yannick jadot à tort c'est yannick jadot
pardon c'est naturel d'aller dans chaque
état membre et c'est vrai que la hongrie
voilà il envie d'y aller ne n'était pas
dévorer par cette envie donc il y est
allé mais comme un geste effectivement
de diplomatie par contre les pays du
groupe de visegrad leurs dirigeants sont
des exemples de terrible en europe parce
qu'ils sont comme le co vie d'un qui
contamine et on voit bien que débat
présidentiel français avec à la fois
eric zemmour et madame le pen qui se
rendent chez lui qui sont d'ailleurs
très bien reçus contrairement aux tapes
d'ailleurs sont très très bien reçus et
s'en servent en politique intérieure
comme d'un exemple donc c'est une vrai
risque pour l'europe que ces pays qui en
fait très de manière très subtile c'est
probablement hors ban qui le sait de
manière la plus chine sont à certains
moments mine de respecter un certain
nombre de principes mais pour mieux les
contrôler et de manière plus efficace en
gardant en façade un semblant
d'appartenance à l'union européenne donc
c'est avec toute notre énergie
démocratique nos valeurs
l'inertie du président macron aussi qui
va falloir
aller de l'avant et rappelé le besoin
par exemple d'une évidence d'une presse
libre pour que nos démocraties
fonctionne et aussi d'une justice
indépendante
ce qui n'est plus le cas dans ces quatre
pays du groupe de visegrad je vais vous
redonner la parole et les hissa dans un
instant joue on parlera du soft power
finalement de cet objectif des macros à
l'occasion de cette visite mais je
voudrais que vous débarquiez un peu
pierre conesa avec fabienne keller parce
que quand elle parle de contamination je
vous vois réagir vous pensez que le mot
est trop fort non c'est prendre le
problème à l'envers c'est à dire si des
gens comme zemmour ou comme madame le
pen ou comme victor sorbonne ont une
base électorale il faut prendre le
problème à l'envers ça il faut se
demander pourquoi ils ont une base
électorale et pas les diaboliser donc
s'ils voulaient commencer par prendre la
question de la tête de turc en disant
mais regardez si en plus ils se
regroupent alors je veux dire c'est le
fascisme en marche non moi la question
que pose sorbonne est une question que
je trouve très fondamentale pour
l'europe c'est à dire où met-on la
limite de ce qui est le consensus
européen et du droit national
les anglais viennent de quitter l'europe
c'est quand même la plus grave crise
depuis sa création bon et on a
aujourd'hui un dirigeant encore une fois
et urée lui le plus long premier
ministre de l'histoire de la hongrie et
qui dit bah écoutez moi regarder
reprenant le par exemple des lgbt il ya
dix ans personne n'en parlait c'est à
dire qu'il ya dix ans on aurait
considéré qu sorbonne était un mauvais
démocrate et aujourd'hui on pose la
question sur la table notre attention là
ça devient un critère sérieux de
démocratie mais non non encore une fois
il ya un moment où il faut arrêter cette
mécanique européenne oui ça c'est le
chemin de l'histoire face à son nom mais
le cheval gvt on n'en parlait pas il ya
dix ans mais enfin c'est quand même au
coeur de l'égalité entre oui mais aux
âmes et les fans oui mais encore une
fois vous pouvez très bien avoir des
normes qui sont différentes de pays
comment allez-vous savoir par exemple le
nombre de transgenre que vous avez en
hongrie alors que leur problème
principal c'est l'immigration et beauté
il faut quand même aussi respecter les
choix prioritaires d'un pays d'une
opinion publique largement fantasmée le
problème grâce voir en hongrie il ya
aucun migrant qui rentrent en hongrie ah
bon tiens donc c'est celui qui les a vu
transiter le plus de tous les pays de
transit et ses 10 millions de personnes
risquent quasiment rien dans mes transit
et oui mais encore une fois il y a aucun
migrant qui
vous nier le fait démocratique
c'est-à-dire escaut sorbonne et une
représentativité sans espoir non on a
passé cinq minutes à essayer de a essayé
c'est pas facile de caractériser la
démocratie libérale et vous faites comme
si démocratie libérale égale démocratie
libérale c'est pas tout à fait râler
libéral un jeu rappelle
vous avez raison de dire qu obama est
élu trois fois de rang et peut-être le
sera-t-il une quatrième mais on peut pas
faire comme si les élections en gris
c'était pareil que les élections en
france où des élections en espagne les
vous dise madame que en russie
effectivement les élections étaient
truquées mais vous reconnaissez qu'en
hongrie elles ne le sont pas donc encore
une fois attention à ne pas
le le ranger j'ai besoin de le
reconnaître parce que j'ai jamais dit
l'un vers premièrement et deuxièmement
on a aussi expliqué qu' il n'y a plus de
presse d'opposition
et bien sûr la question de dg bts on
peut aussi considérer que dans dans les
valeurs de l'europe il y à la défense de
ses de ces minorités et que donc par les
lois qui sont prises par viktor orban ya
une remise en cause de ses valeurs oui
mais encore une fois ces valeurs sont
récentes c'est à dire que vous auriez
poser le même problème sur orbagna 10
ans qui était déjà un libéral vous
n'auriez pas qualifiés comme mauvais
partenaires de l'union européenne encore
une fois c'était ce sont des pays qui
ont une histoire différente de la nôtre
leur souci nationaliste si vous voulez
beaucoup plus à vif que nous qui avons
construit l'europe donc l'idée vous
regardez que les polonais regarder avec
lecce avec les les endroits où ils
avaient effectivement le souci je
résiste
je voudrais que fabienne télé reprises
vous réponds je voudrais rappeler que
nul ne peut être discriminé en fonction
de sa religion son orientation sexuelle
c'est dans la convention européenne des
droits de l'homme à laquelle l'union
européenne a adhéré
en entrant dans l'union européenne en
lors tous les pays des dix pays y
compris la hongrie ont accepté l'acquis
communautaire et se sont assuré de la
conformité de leur constitution à
l'ensemble de de ce corpus donc que ce
soit aujourd'hui remise en cause par
certains états membres c'est une
décision récente puisque toutes les
évolutions devait être négocié de bonne
foi et éventuellement donner lieu à des
adaptations soit détecte nationaux soit
de la constitution mais ces divergences
qu'il semble découvrir aujourd'hui c'est
pas du tout hein c'est historique c'est
un fait volontaire de la part de la
hongrie comme d'ailleurs de la pologne
après je maintiens qu'il a une stratégie
de stigmatisation un certain nombre de
groupes sociaux et les lgbt y sont au
coeur il va organiser un référendum je
vous invite à lire les questions de ce
référendum vous ne pouvez pas voter
contre sorbonne en fait parce que les
questions sont trop caricatural il sera
donc il obtiendra donc
résultat qui sera très impressionnant
j'ai rencontré l'adjoint au maire de
budapest cet été qui m'a expliqué la
mise en place d'une taxe sur les mairies
sur la base d'un critère soit disant
objective mais dans la pratique sur des
mairie tenue par des maires d'opposition
voilà une bonne technique pour
encourager des hongrois optez plutôt
pour des personnes favorables à monsieur
sorbonne c'est tout un système que nos
collègues dans mon groupe il ya deux
collègues hongroise très engagée dans
l'opposition à monsieur sorbonne nous
décrypte régulièrement c'est très subtil
c'est ça neil libéralisme et ça a les
apparences parfois peu la démocratie
mais ça a tous les outils des régimes
autoritaires et populistes comme cela a
été dit tout à l'heure
je pense que ce qui est intéressant ce
moment sur l'union européenne parce
qu'en fait c'est sa ligne de fracture
c'est qu'il faut absolument apprendre à
se rencontrer et c'est pour ça que
quelque part la visite de macron delà
des questions européennes
de politique intérieure et sert à elle
reste fondamental parce qu'on en parle
et en fait quand on regarde tous ces
pays là on voit que lille ont des
ruptures qui sont des ruptures
historiques qui ne sont pas les mêmes
que les nôtres et quand là on a une
frontière entre l'europe occidentale et
l'europe qui est plus centrale on a une
fracture qui effectivement par des
années de communisme qui fait que bien
le rappeler que ces pays retrouve la
liberté qui retrouve une économie qui
retrouve de l'argent et donc ils ne sont
pas près tout de suite à le partager
parce que lorsque vous discutez avec des
gens de notre âge ils vont tout de suite
vous rappeler leurs années de communisme
quand il était privé de pain ou de
viande et que donc il devait faire une
grande que au supermarché des choses
qu'on n'a pas connues nous donc du coup
ils ont encore cet appétit là ils vont
regarder la question migratoire
parce que derrière ils ont aussi
l'histoire commune avec l' empire
ottoman qui a effectivement à un moment
donné était sur leurs terres et donc y
rester plus d'un siècle effectivement là
dessus et donc tout cela ça permet en
fait d'aller discuter d'aller parler
d'aller comprendre pourquoi est ce qu'il
ya un entregent pourquoi est ce que pour
nous ça va pas nous effrayer mais pour
eux ça va encore être effrayant pourquoi
est-ce qu'il faut s'en prémunir y
compris effectivement sur la notion de
valeurs chrétiennes qui est aussi la
notion refuge
ces pays là comme maintenant la russie
qui joue l'orthodoxie et tout ça en fait
à partir du moment donné où on arrive à
comprendre que les choses se font pas à
la même vitesse des pays les uns avec
les autres on comprend j'allais dire
mieux avec plus de tolérance ce qui est
en train de se passer ce sont les pays
qui se construisent aujourd'hui avec une
autre vision en disant votre vision
européenne occidentale elle nous fait
pas rêver nous vous ne fait pas rêver
quand vous êtes dans un entrain de nous
parler des questions trans genres vous
nous faites pas rêver quand vous êtes en
train d'expliquer qu' il faut que toute
l'europe soit ouverte et qu'on accueille
le flux de chacun donc la seule manière
à un moment donné de comprendre pourquoi
ce qu'ils disent il nous faut vous nous
faites pas rêver c'est pas de la fermer
la porte parce que sinon on rend l'agora
et on a besoin de s'exprimer on a besoin
de leur ouvrir la porte de dire pourquoi
et là on évitera peut-être que certains
populistes et on discutera davantage
avec les gens et ce qui est intéressant
laetitia c'est que c'est exactement
finalement ce que emmanuel macron a
annoncé quand je parlais de soft power
il a clairement visé c'est exactement
c'est exactement l'enjeu des manuels
macron c'est de convaincre les hongrois
n'ont pas viktor orban nuit même mais la
population hongroise et il a dit en juin
dernier justement comme quand viktor
orban s'était fait un peu remonté les
bretelles rappelé à l'ordre par la
commission européenne
à cause de cette loi qui interdit la
représentation de l'homosexualité pour
les moins de 18 ans en marge de ce
sommet manuel mâcon a pris la parole et
à assumer de façon officielle sa
stratégie est écoutée
doit faire un travail au corps à corps
avec les systèmes politiques médiatiques
les organisations sociales les
intellectuels dans ces pays
d'abord pour montrer qu'on ne cédera
rien ensuite étape par étape
sanctionnés justement les états membres
qui vont dans cette direction mais aussi
faire oeuvre de pédagogie et de
conviction et montrer aux sociétés
civiles que c'est une régression
terrible vers lesquels elles ont faut
être dur avec les dirigeants et
convaincant avec les peuples c'est
intéressant à cette position dure avec
les dirigeants via les les voies de la
commission européenne donc on le sait un
il ya des process qui sont mis en place
pour conditionner ou pas certaines aides
en fonction des positions des états mais
en fait le projet d' emmanuel macron
c'est de convaincre la population
hongroise peut-être ne pas réélire
viktor orban ne me l'avait dit pour
l'instant il est réélu on verra bien ce
qui arrive en avril mais en tout cas
c'est assumer officiellement d'habitude
ce soft power comme ça cette ingérence
indirects finalement est plutôt dit en
coulisses en aux faits et là c'est
assumé sur la scène européenne alors il
ne dit pas par quel moyen il va
atteindre cet objectif
est-ce-qu'il comment on en arrive à
influencer les médias hongrois comment
on arrive à toucher les intellectuels il
ya certainement tout un réseau un en
coulisse mise en place français pour
aller par les hongrois n'ont en tout cas
les ponts et les passerelles sont
effectivement construite et puis sylvain
kahn au delà de ces leviers que cannes
emmanuel macron que de l'influencé
française pourrait voilà pourrait
s'activer en hongrie bonjour moi j'ai un
peu l'impression que le prix en français
pourront peut-être aussi un peu ses
désirs pour des réalités mais ce qu'il
faut pas oublier dans cette visite là
c'est qu'il ya des terrains d'entente et
ya même des stratégiquement des points
d'entente a travaillé entre la france et
la hongrie dans la perspective de la
présidence française de l'union qui
démarre en janvier oui bah ça de toute
façon disons il n'y a pas même si ça
fait un peu étrange de dire ça il n'y a
pas que l'état de droit comme dossier
qui est sur la table mais juste pour
revenir sur ce qui a été dit
précédemment
l'union enfin qu'en dire je crois que
l'on gagnerait à considérer l'union
européenne comme tendanciellement comme
étant un pays c'est à dire que dire les
hongrois sont comme si les polonais sont
comme ça les anciens pays communistes
ont comme si c'est comme si on disait
imaginons que alors qu'on est plutôt on
est on est sur un plateau d'une émission
politique française et qu'on faisait
comme si les la france et les français
le buzz a été un seul bloc alors que dès
qu'on parle de la vie politique
française on l'avait montré à travers
vos reportages on est extrêmement
sensible aux nuances aux différences aux
confrontations aux oppositions mais
l'europe c'est pareil c'est à dire que
moi je crois qu'il faut voir emmanuel
macron en l'occurrence là en ce moment
comme le représentant d'un
un d'une grande partie de la société
politique et de la société européenne
tout court qui est majoritaire et puis
viktor orban comme on va dire le porte
parole sans doute le plus intelligent
d'une de la partie minoritaire de la
société politique et de la société
européenne encore une fois le maire de
budapest fait partie de l'opposition en
gris on parlait de vigie grade tout à
l'heure le premier minis l'ancien
premier ministre tchèque andrés babiche
qui est
poursuivi par la justice de son pays
pour des faits de corruption des
détournements d'argent notamment
européens vient de perdre le pouvoir il
a été mise en minorité donc faut faire
attention c'est pas c'est pas tout les
tchèques qui sont des libéraux enfin oui
et tout ça c'est en mouvement et quand
macron va en hongrie rencontrer tout le
monde on est bien dans le cadre
finalement d'un débat européen et le
parlement européens reflète ça donc ça
jugé est ce que vous pensez qu'il a une
capacité par sa visite à influencer à
même à minima le scrutin
intérieure orwa oui encore une fois
parce que
il faut avoir une vision d'ensemble du
tableau c'est comme quand le
gouvernement polonais actuelle donc
mazowiecki kaczinsky a adoptée a fait
adopter par son parlement la législation
sur les vg l'interruption de grossesse
la plus restrictives d'europe et l'une
des plus restrictives du monde voilà
effectivement et ça contrevient à la
charte de l'union européenne des droits
fondamentaux à la convention européenne
des droits de l'homme et c'est bon il ya
eu des manifestations monstres dans
toutes les villes de pologne et il ya eu
en écho des manifestations dans tout un
tas de pays européens qui se sentaient
concernés de la même manière que si
c'était chez eux voilà donc il ya une
vie politique à l'échelle européenne
mais ce que je peux poser une question
très naïve alors peut-être que les
français se posent quel serait le
problème si la hongrie ou la pologne
sortait de l'union européenne bah c'est
un problème pour eux
comme j'ai reconnaissent à l'adie la
hongrie ses 10 millions d'habitants
c'est un peu ce serait pas une perte
énorme pour l'union ben tout dépend de
quel point de vue on se place mais en
termes de poids ça représente pas grand
chose mais en termes on va dire de deux
projets politiques jacques delors disait
quelque chose du genre de toute façon
s'il ya des pays qui sont problématiques
ou avec lesquels on est en tension il
vaut mieux qu'on est les tensions à
l'intérieur c'est ce qu'à l'extérieur
oui mais on irait certainement la
possibilité à d'autres pays de s'en
aller parce que l'europe elle fonctionne
aussi par clans en quelque sorte donc là
pour l'instant on a laissé les anglais
ils braquent site mais si les polonais
avec le pôle excite dont on parle venait
à s'en aller il ya d'autres pays qui se
diraient pas pourquoi pas finalement est
ce que c'est la stratégie de la hongrie
ça c'est plutôt rangé dans l'europe pour
la faire évoluer ce n'est pas frustrant
pas à sortir mais si vous voulez il faut
prendre le film dans sa continuité
ancrer le marché commun on chez commun
c'était simple suffisait d' abaisser les
frontières et en été entre le pays qui
avait à peu près des économies de même
niveau bon et puis progressivement met
en place un projet politique encore une
fois avec des gens qui avaient des
trajectoires des pays qui avaient des
trajectoires politiques assez comparable
et puis il ya tout à coup ce
bouleversement stratégique de la
disparition de l'urss de l'ouverture des
pays de l'est qui vont s'intégrer
évidemment non seulement dans le dans
l'union européenne mais dans le temps
bon et donc on a aussi vous voulez une
entité dont l'historique est tout à fait
différente
m découvrir que si vous voulez on puisse
avoir des points de vue divergents dans
cette construction à 27,29 peu combien
on en est là aujourd'hui mais on est
quand même quelque chose qui par nature
est hétérogène et donc si on se met dans
une position de censeur morale en disant
attention les clés de l'état de droit
vous savez moi je suis très fasciné par
cette notion d'état de droit je vais
vous en citer un exemple quand en 1948
on adopte la convention internationale
des droits de l'homme les cinq pays
membres du punk conseil de sécurité
c'est les états unis qui sont
ségrégationniste et raciste c'est la
russie de staline c'est la chine de
l'embellie tchèque et c'est la france et
la grande bretagne qui sont les deux
grandes puissances coloniales de la
planète donc s'ils voulaient en matière
d'état de droite c'est faites ce que je
dis faites pas ce que je fais donc on
est sur quelque chose ou si on déplace
les limites de l'état de droit en
rajoutant à chaque fois des sujets on va
dire oui mais attendez vous rendez
compte que vous ne remplissez pas toutes
les cases donc un moment où il faut
accepter qui est une espèce de
frontières entre l'identité de chacun si
les polonais votent contre lille et j'ai
c'est parce que c'est très
fondamentalement un pays tout atomique
etc ce pays catholique c'est parce qu'il
était catholique il à résister à l'air
et c'est ce dont vous n'avez pas tout à
coup nier le fait que y ait cet
arrière-fond enfin devant moi je n'y
rien ça fait deux fois que vous me dites
vous reconnaissez-vous non mais écoutez
moi non mais c'est vrai que vous voyez
bien que l'exemple de la pologne est
l'exemple même transposer de quelque
chose vous avez l'identité nationale qui
pensent que la loi européenne n'est pas
la norme qui veulent appliquer chez eux
il faut le reconnaître il ya une
majorité élue au parlement polonais qui
pensent ça et il ya 80% des femmes
polonaises qui sont pas d'accord il faut
mais ya quand même des dirigeants d'un
débat démocratique qui a créé son parti
et qui a certainement ou peut-être en
tout cas croit thiélin destin avec la
france qui veulent revenir à une europe
très resserrée 1 c'est un projet qui est
sur le papier massi soit 7 enfin je veux
dire c'est pas non plus
posé sur la table non mais on se rend
compte que l'état de droit si les
centrales après c'est quelle place à
l'état de droit dans l'union européenne
est ce que oui ou non c'est la condition
sinequanone pour appartenir à l'union
européenne on peut se la poser cette
question si c'est oui dans ces cas là il
faut resserrer l'europe autour des pays
qui respecte l'état de droit et puis je
vous demander finition européenne fabien
je reprends la map avant qu'il a sonné
ça pour donner la parole une dernière
fois à fabienne keller et je reviens à
la question je posais à sylvain kahn
tout à l'heure sur l'un des enjeux parce
qu'on l'a pas vraiment abordés de la
visite des manuels macron c'est
effectivement d'aller chercher quand
même viktor orban et la hongrie comme un
allié potentiel sur certains dossiers je
pense notamment au nucléaire on sait
qu'il ya une question très importante
qui se joue en ce moment entre la france
et l'allemagne sur ce qu'on appelle la
taxonomie verte c'est-à-dire comment
l'europe va flécher le financement de la
transition écologique et énergétique est
ce que le nucléaire on fera partie là
c'est un allié de la france victor c'est
un allié de sept puisque à peu près la
moitié de son énergie est d'origine
nucléaire comme là c'est bien son style
il dit être allié sur la souveraineté
européenne et l'autonomie stratégique il
a même symboliquement envoyé quelques
soldats pour la force t'as bu cas au
mali
mais là aussi identifions bien ça sa
finesse il n'a pas tort sur tout et je
ne mords pas du tout qu'il souhaite
sortir de l'union d'abord parce que ses
concitoyens ne le souhaite pas ils sont
très europhile il circule d'ailleurs
beaucoup en europe 1-le les
intellectuels et les personnes du monde
de l'économie
travail avec circulent dans tout dans
toute l'europe ça n'est pas souhaitable
et l'europe le finance très fortement et
à aider et continuer à aider massivement
la transition de l'ensemble de son
économie
donc il est réaliste il veut rester dans
l'europe et c'est là qu'il faut qu'il
accepte qu'il ya des règles quand on est
en europe il ya des valeurs communes des
valeurs démocratiques et moi je serais
beaucoup plus optimiste ça et quand la
grèce le portugal et l'espagne ont
rejoint l'union européenne il sortait de
dictature militaire
l'économie a permis d'accompagner et de
consolider une démocratie une croissance
qui a nourri voilà une évolution de ces
pays qui qui a permis l'émergence de
régimes stables ça n'est pas pour
l'instant le cas de manière aussi
positive dans les pays dits de l'est moi
je forme le voeu que cette dynamique
européenne ce projet partagé par
l'ensemble de ce peuple européen qui a
été décrit tout à l'heure et bien puisse
amener l'ensemble des pays de l'est à ce
respect des valeurs fondamentales
auxquelles nous sommes très attachés et
qui les ont tous tous les hongrois a
accepté en 2004 merci beaucoup merci à
tous d'avoir participé à ce débat je
rappelle le titre de vos ouvrages
respectifs sylvain kahn histoire de la
construction de l'europe depuis 1945 aux
puf et pierre connaissait le lobby
saoudien en france comment vendre un
pays invendable c'est aux éditions
denoël merci à tous encore une fois